this game I prepared to show you is from
2012 World Championship match between
Vichy amount and Boris Gelfand and we
looked at Game seven last Thursday where
Gelfand won if you remember and but
immediately the very next game he
actually lost very badly here in this
game so I'd like to show you this game
and we can analyze so it was very
important because Anand managed to win
right away to equalize the match so he
decided to play d4 Knight f6 c4 g6 and a
couple of games before a girlfriend
played groom felt so that looks like
this was his opening for the match and
he didn't have any problems so he was
making relatively easy draws so that's
why now in this game he plays amount
plays f3 it's a sharp move because he
wants to play efore here so very very
sharp idea like let's say if you still
play d5 takes Knight takes e4 and white
will get to control the center develop
the knight on c3 so it leads to a very
sharp positions so Gelfand didn't play
that he decided to play c5 attacking the
center so now white plays d5 d6 d4 can
you tell me which opening now this looks
like in which variation because it's not
groom field anymore
so which opening you think this is yes
no not London usually no we keep the
pawn on d4 in London this is yes this is
a King's Indian opening in which
variation this looks like Samish correct
yeah this is the King's Indian opening
same ish same issue variation so Bishop
g7 played here and let's say if you
played Knight c3 here it would just be
the the same ish but here anon played
more rare move 92 in fact I've played
this move a couple of times myself this
was played yeah after seeing this game I
actually used this opening and I wanna
in a pretty nice game against the strong
Grandmaster the point of this move is in
the main Sameach line the big problem is
where to put this Knight
let me just explain to you so you can
understand clearly
so Knight e 2 e 6 white really has a
problem where to put this night because
he needs to move this Knight to develop
his Bishop so he can castle so
oftentimes they put a knight on G 3
where actually the knight doesn't it's
not placed well here at all because
cannot go anywhere and oftentimes black
plays H 5 and H 4 as well to attack this
Knight
so that's why the knight is always a
problem where to develop this Knights
and the point of this move is you play
Knight e 2 and if Castle he wants to put
this knight on c3 and if for some reason
you play e6 just a natural development
and then I can simply go 92 and 94 see
how nice Knight will be on c4 now that's
a very good outpost putting pressure on
d6 and you can even play Bishop f4 apply
more pressure here
so that's why they play the move 92 of
course it's not so easy there are other
responses black can do but it's very
interesting so if you don't know what to
do against King's Indian you may look at
this game a couple of other games you'll
see my game against now Master butch
Cove where I also play this move and and
one it's not a bad system it's very it's
still sharp but it's very interesting
ninety-two Galvin was probably still
well-prepared because for World
Championship you study everything you
study the main lines the rare lines the
lines that you probably shouldn't study
you study all the lines because you
never know what opponent gonna do but
this is very short play from Anand
immediately this you know after losing
the previous game he's trying to
equalize here very sharp so he cancelled
and as I mentioned unite e to see three
if he plays Knight B to C three just
transposed the main Sameach lines with
the c5 so night EC tree and now there
are several moves here as I mentioned is
six one there is also ninety-six
interesting move and Knight h5 novelty
by gelfand and his team here but it says
he spent a lot of time here so perhaps
it was over the board novelty or
something because at that time this was
a still a very new idea 92-93 became
very fashionable after this game because
any interesting or new idea played at
the world championship level people
gonna look immediately and try to
analyze and play Knight h5 the move
looks a little bit shaky because you're
putting the knight on the side of the
board which is not ideal but the point
is black wants to play in f5 immediately
to try to open the position here to try
to get contra play and here Bishop g5
interesting move to try to put pressure
of course he could have also played the
Muji for forcing the knight back which
looks natural but after h5h for you have
an attack but he also can play six so
it's gonna get a little bit complicated
here
black will try to open the center and
it's definitely sharp now he wants to
play b5 it looks like white is close
to try to deliver a strong attack but
it's it's very difficult because you
don't have that much development see
pieces are not developed when your pills
are not developed then you don't have
pieces to mate with so you're gonna need
to spend some time to develop those
pieces so an employee Bishop c5 and both
players are playing the way that you can
see that they're just kind of
experimenting so these are not the moves
that you would actually sit and analyze
with the computer so Bishop g5 trying to
pin the pawn on e7
he played Bishop f6 trying to get rid of
the strong bishop that is causing some
problems there another alternative here
is h6 here but I could understand
gelfand for not playing this one because
you don't really want to push the palms
in front of the King because later on
after Queen d2 it's gonna be a problem
you will be pressured so that's why I
played Bishop f6 Bishop takes f6
and now he can take back with a knight
which I think it's a very natural move
and it's quite surprising
why gelfand was playing such a risky
such a such a risky way in this game
because he had the lead or it didn't
match and he could just play it normal
and for example 'if I've now Center is
closed and it's it's playable position
it's about equal but he played very
concrete took back with a pawn and again
he wants to play this idea f5 but now
Queen d2 good move what is the idea
behind this move can you tell me why he
played that move Queen d2 do you see
what he's trying to achieve here
exactly well first he's taking this
square under control and then when he
plays G for the night cannot come there
so f5 trying to undo all the double
pounds and now if you allow block to
play f4 like let's say you make a
natural move but you allow f4 it's gonna
be a big mistake Bishop d3 because after
f4 block is just better because he will
play 97-95
and then he has a very strong night
there and the center is completely
locked so it'll be no counter play block
will be very active here so here taking
it's pretty much forced of course taking
back with a pawn it's out of question
because it weakens the position of the
king and creates a lot of weaknesses but
here's a gift front to back with the
bishop there were some other
alternatives check with the rook and
take it actually transposes to almost
the game so that's an idea as well
another one was Queen h4 check
but King d1 Bishop takes a5g4 trying to
win some material this should be 1 rupee
197 and King C to me this looks not so
clear 97 Queen e1 takes maybe white is a
little bit better but this is very deep
analysis after the game the game
finishes and then of course during the
game even very strong ramus is very
difficult to play like this because you
the moves are not clear I just wanted to
show you that afterwards analysis point
out that you know it was about equal yes
so he took Bishop takes f5 and g4
again it was just a very risky play here
by gelfand that's why he lost this game
and actually he blunders something as
well
it's very concrete dispossession so here
he played rook e8 and this is slightly
dubious already here again batteries to
play Queen h4 check King to d1 capture
and transpose this to the previous line
basically where we exchanged Queens so
about equal position rook e8 now he paid
king d1 again this is still a fork so
you have to do something so he took on
b1 Luke takes b1 and here comes the
blunder
he should have he played Queen f6
thinking that white needs to protect f3
otherwise he will just win the rock but
he missed an idea there he should have
just played here Knight f6 but after
King c2 white is better because he will
go Bishop d3 h4 White is slightly better
also white is better after 97 h4 yeah
but this it's still it's still long game
here it's not so clear I mean white
White has a better position but it's not
like white is winning here so he played
Queen f6 now let's see now if you can
see the winning idea for white from now
on it was only 17 moves in this game one
of the shortest games in the World
Championship okay
check correct
it's rook
bishop the problem is i take the pawn on
h2 correct that's the move he missed
actually he missed the move Queen f2
because that way now he controls the
square and getting ready to play Bishop
d3 and the Queen on h1 is gonna get
trapped see that's the problem here the
queen is gonna be trapped on h1 you move
the bishop the Queen is just trapped now
so he has to go here and Bishop to d3
trapping the Queen
he designed here right here yeah you
know there was a very nice documentary
actually and then girl phone mentioned
that he was so upset he not that again
that he not to have the lead and then
just you know give it away like this you
know very very painful loss you know
where but he just he played too risky
when you play a risky then you know the
position is gonna get sharp and you're
just gonna miss one move he just really
missed this move he just really missed
this idea he probably looked at this and
he saw that he has you know ideas like
Queen g'wan escaping you speak escaping
to default for example but he just
completely overlooked Queen f2 and after
which 97 should he just drops the Queen
he resigned because if he takes King
takes hey you could have played on but
it's just it's just not enough it's just
not enough compensation here because
essentially he is playing down a piece
so that's why okay let's see let's go
back and just review this game to make
sure because it's a quite a complex game
here it's one of the most complicated
games at least in opening stages so
let's review one more time doing over
review of the game to make sure we
understand a little bit better and then
I have some very good endgame positions
for you after okay to improve your
endgame technique so let's start now
first move go ahead d4 Knight f6 second
move c4 so Gelfand is aiming for a
groove felt and now didn't have much
success with it so he didn't want groom
felt or he wanted a very sharp version
of grupa so that's why he played this
unusual move and a movers f3 yes and now
Tate c5 attacking c5 is kind of
interesting because white is weakening
the dark squares so c5 is very direct to
the point so d5 continued
d6 so when you play f3 you want to put
your pawn where II four so the name of
the opening is now Kings Indian defense
correct which variation is this same ish
can't remain the same ish yeah the same
issue came up with couple of systems in
like this is one and he has also same
each system in nimzo-indian defense as
well now what did he play here Knight e
to correct and Kate do you remember do
you remember why he played this move
what is it trying to do he's trying to
put that night not this night this is
like automatic move but we don't want to
do we want to put this Knight here
because in this savage system the
problem is always this night on g1 to
where to put him
ok so that's why he wants to put it on
c3 and then later on he will decide on
what to do with this Knight likely to go
to d2 + c4 if it's available or some
other squares so that's kind of a deep
idea I like it I was you know I really
like this idea that that's why I played
a couple of times myself this so Castle
93
Knight h5 trying to be sharp
activating his Bishop Bishop f6 again if
you check this game with the computer
don't be surprised if computer suggests
completely different moves because
they're on their own even though it's
World Championship they're completely on
their own here I think because the
position is very complex there are
several other ways to play it's not like
no you have to play this way only there
are many different ways how you can play
in this opening so but you choose to
play Bishop f6 but in general it's a
risky thing to do in the King's Indian
to exchange the dark square bishop
because we know that that's the bishop
you want to keep because your king is
not as safe once you exchange that
bishop so this decision was this is the
moment where it became already a little
bit risky so what did what did a nun
play here Bishop takes Bishop he takes
f6 again playing it too risky there was
absolutely no need to go for those
complications he could have just taken
back Queen d2 and just played the e5
move and I mean probably computer will
say white is a little bit better because
of the space advantage the pawn on d5 is
giving him space but it's just
absolutely playable position here so no
no major no major problems here for
black my impression also this game is
that Gelfand didn't want to go for a
slightly worse position so perhaps those
positions he evaluated is slightly worse
for him and he didn't want to kind of
suffer so he wanted to go for something
more concrete so that's why he made this
decision say took back of the pawn now
what did a nun play Queen d2 developing
a piece controlling the F for square so
he can play g4 and at some point even
Queen h6 is a possibility and now we're
gonna see why it was not a very good
idea perhaps to exchange the dark square
Bishop f5 makes sense because that's the
reason that's the only reason he took
back with the pawn so you can play a 5
now it's gonna get complicated you have
to as we discussed if you play a very
natural-looking Bishop d3 move again it
takes f4 it's again a very difficult
move to play because your king is in the
middle you opening up a line this is
very risky thing to do but he has to
because otherwise he could be just worse
B should be three f4 immediately Knight
d7 97-95 it's a fantastic outpost for
the night only five and block will be
just dominating this and then he
suggested he five but it's just not
enough because you don't have enough
development another active move we try
to play it short to secure the g5 square
but it doesn't work f5 9 GF 6 n
eventually this efore pawn will start
marching down if 43 and black will win
so that if I've idea doesn't work we do
need to look for this ideas okay so it's
important idea to look it's just here we
don't have enough development if we had
the night owl we were canceled we might
have been able to play that but not
right now so takes again there were a
lot of alternatives Gelfand could have
played safer but he played the way he
wanted so play Bishop f5 now g4 rook e8
another inaccuracy Queen h4 was
suggested and this leads to that end
game that we looked at it
Bishop d1 or actually it can even play
Queen f2 even exchange Queens Bishop e1
move move the knight should be okay for
black no big problems but he played rook
e8 check a nun ghost King d1 and now
it's fork so he has to take on b1 and
here again he could have just moved the
night but then he probably went for this
idea a couple of moves before and I
think he might have moved quickly here
because he just he was sure that this is
this is main idea because I'm
he wouldn't go for this position because
both retreats are worse for him if he
goes there h4 h5 white is clearly better
here it's still a game it's still a long
game anything can happen but white is
better that's one thing is clear because
here we'll just play Bishop d3 king c2
and then h5 is coming very unpleasant
and launched a strong attack if he goes
Knight f6 again King c2 and as the
yellow our arrows are showing you Bishop
d3 h4 h5 white is better so he didn't
want to go for this position I think
couple of moves earlier he anticipated
this position and he said I'm gonna play
the move Queen f6 which he did but this
is turn out to be a blunder and resulted
in one of the shortest games in the
world championship history do you
remember what happened pawn takes knight
Czech Queen f2 excellent I did then you
wanna this is what the move that he
missed the move Queen f2 because he
thought you know if Queen a for koenji
what he can say but he missed Queen f2
and now the Queen is trapped very very
unfortunate situation and he resigned
here because Bishop d3 is coming let me
ask you a question if upon a place
Knight a6
what do you need to do here because
obviously this this move has one purpose
right to check you write a three yes you
can play a three that's that's
absolutely fine you can also yeah I
think this that's the simplest thing to
do just greatly to just stop the idea
don't try to work make the line work you
might you might be able to still win his
queen but it might get complicated okay
so you don't want that you want to just
work the line just stop his threat
opponent makes a move creating a threat
you just stop it and then your threat is
still there he's king you know his queen
is in the box it's not moving so then
you go Bishop d3 and win the game so he
resigned and this this helped announced
to equalize the match and eventually
they the match and
didn't draw and then they went tie
breaks and a nun won by very minimal
margin two and a half one and a half in
the playoffs to retain his title okay so
this is the game the world championship
game today and now I have some endgame
positions for you so let's start out
with this position this is a game played
by a world champion Vladimir Kramnik
that's a very very nice play and he
played against a very strong player
Alexander Milosevic very one of the most
creative players he's not as active
anymore but when he is on fire he could
he couldn't win against anybody he was
actually almost 2800 a few years ago so
it's too bad we don't see him that you
know playing more now okay so this is
the game Kramnik is white in this game
and as you can see he has what we call a
positional advantage why does he have
the positional advantage here who can
tell me the reasons why white is better
here passed pawn and what kind of pass
band this is protected pass pawn not
just a pastime because if you just a
passed pawn it could be a weak one it
could be a liability but here it's
protected past pawn when there is no
pawn that can stop him that's a passed
pawn right and it's protected so that's
one plus what else you can mention here
do you look at the structures when you
see a position I think the very first
thing you need to do is look at the pawn
structure so when you look at that what
do you see here what do you see here
black has double pants that's correct
and usually when you have a double pawn
it could result in two extra pawn island
okay how many pawn islands you see here
four black 3 right 1 2 & 3 so double
pawns that's why they not good there
they're not just weak they actually
split from the other pants usually and
become more more islands now three three
porn islands for black what about white
how many pawn islands will to correct
now Bishop versus Knight Bishop is more
active because it's putting pressure
also on f6 on the weak upon as well but
you know it's not easy to play this
position if you don't play correctly
right now you you will not have any
advantage here nothing will be left so
let's play like Kramnik here
aha and the movies well excellent you
just play like kramnik very good fixing
the weakness on f6 and preparing to play
rook f3 okay
g4 very good again he's fixing this
weakness and threatening to play rook f3
to put pressure on it very strong move
g4 see you need to realise when to play
g4 and when not to play g4 because
sometimes you play the move like this it
weakens your King and then you lose and
you like I'm never gonna do this so you
you have to you know you have to realize
when to do it first of all it's an
endgame right if there were Queens on
the board
we'll likely we're not gonna do it so
but they're not Queens on the board so
that's why we do it and second it's
gaining space and in the main idea of
course we stop Knight f5 Knight g6
played by Mauro savage attacking the
bishop
so the second next move is pretty much
forced it's under attack so he goes
Bishop g3 and now he played a5 you know
thinking there are no immediate threats
I can just play this move and now it's
actually you know he it's good to
advance the spawns
too so you can have some breaks or
something so it's it's a5 is a normal
move now which piece we can improve here
and activate we could go Roxy one that's
a fine move - what is the advantage of
having a protected passed pawn when it's
already a little bit advanced it gives
you an outpost for your pieces in his
territory okay like for example Knight
would have been nice here right but we
don't have a knight here Bishop d6 C
whenever you can make a move like this
to put a piece in his position like that
that's a very good idea you should do it
because now you're activating your
bishop and do you see now the bishop is
kind of dominating the night because the
squares the knight can go to are simply
taken by your bishop so bishop is
dominating the night here in this
position so there should be six and the
plan here actually if white just
continue doing what he is doing then the
plan is actually let's see if we can
find it what would be the winning point
here for Kramnik if you're not familiar
with kramnik is a former world champion
run a very very tough flesh currently
number two actually in the world so yes
you could go rook c1 but him you play
rook c6 and you don't really have much
you want to open some lines okay yes f4
f5 great idea and very nice very nice
okay for white okay Oh big advantage big
advantage let's see let's see I'm going
to ask you to answer your question if
you play this move here which will
people play you think which movie will
play tink uh-huh and then I don't think
this Bishop is ever gonna get here now I
don't see how you're gonna get this guy
there so be very careful okay of
blocking your own pieces because then
you might not be able to get out so
Bishop d6 so that's why he can't just
response here I'll just stay because F 4
F 5 is just winning so morisevic
tries to create culture play correctly
so now h 5 trying to maybe do something
on the h file so if you page 3 he just
takes and then rakesh 8 and some some
ideas so you have to take actually here
you take a new attack that's extra pawn
to so he goes Knight to h4 so if he puts
a knight on a5 your rook will not be
able to come to the G file because he
will always control that square so you
start with root g3 check 9 was King h6
and for a moment it looks like maybe we
didn't play very accurately because this
night is gonna land on f5 and we're
gonna likely lose they try pawn and
looks like we may be blundered but he
calculated deeper he calculated deeper
here and very nice play here for for
white again the threat is quite obvious
he wants to go Knight f5 so what to do
against it yes
before check you can but I just take the
pond then I take I don't know I'm not
sure yeah I don't know this is getting a
little bit I know it looks kind of
strange but I don't see threats II know
so I can I think I can play like this
I'm not not too worried yeah well I it's
just the way the pits are it's gonna be
hard to meet here okay so let's see what
else what else you can do here don't let
Knight f5 trade discourage you from
playing the correct move here you're
gonna have to do a positional a
sacrifice here positional sacrifice in
fact you're winning after sacrifice but
to get to that moment to realize that
you can do this that's the that's why
we're doing this position so you can see
that yes
okay and how about 95 did you see 95 for
King the bishop and the rook I don't
stop now tink tink remember I say
positional sacrifice right how about we
sacrifice the rook
they give the exchange but take the pawn
okay now he takes right and now how
you're going to recapture here this is
important very important actually well
the first reaction today could H pawn
there but then are you gonna have an H
pass pond no right so you already have a
very strong protected passed pawn on the
C file if you can have another strong
pass pawn on H file with a powerful
bishop planting on f6 you will slowly
advance you and just push his King back
you will actually win this game so he
actually took with this it's very strong
to just understand that this position is
technically winning for white this is
this is very difficult
now I play drew create trying to
activate a rook he's trying to
discourage g4 you know well he can't
take the pawn - but he's going to take
the pawn next month he's just trying to
discourage the advance but now
kingi two takes and now
no he wants to go King g6 so you want to
control G Foursquare so you can start
pushing okay pushing your pants h3 now I
go skiing g6 attacking your bishop and
now this one is very important you play
because if you move the bishop from f6
you don't have anything you go f6 and
you have to keep the bishop on f6
here.how rook f1 yes complete domination
here bishop cannot be moved from f6 you
got the passed pawn and now you're
getting ready to do this push push come
up and push King gauge for you just keep
pushing you can't do anything here so
Raghavan is good now he played King h7
he pushed g4 you cannot push it what are
you gonna do first
King g3 first very good
now he plays b3 this is where they just
wanna give you a pawn to create some
kind of complication what you're gonna
say huh fix it on atria don't take it
because it will be some counter play
rook a c8 he push rope g6 you push if he
goes here you go King h4 first and then
g5 dropping that rock so you can't do
that well he has to go here but this is
just getting worse and worse now push
push that's permanently trapped and now
you can simply have several ways to win
but you can actually walk this way
that's one plan yeah there are a few
ways you can break through here and win
so yeah it's amazing display of
understanding of this position because
not too many even Grandmaster would just
sacrifice the exchange like that in a
milk in endgame to try to have a
follow-up like this
okay okay so let's review this very
instructive end game by Kramnik again if
you want to find this game this is the
game Kramnik morisevic
Dortmund tournament in 2001 okay okay so
let's review all the way until we're
white is completely winning cash so this
way we can see if you understand the
ideas okay who wants to start first the
first move you need to play like ramnik
yes g4 the idea is what is this move
accomplishing yes
yes it's trying to go to calf three and
fixing very important to remember you
fixing the weakness when opponent has a
weak pawn but he's ready to one double
or advanced you want to fix it okay
fix it later to win it nine to six
Bishop g3 a5 he's just you know he's
just making some useful moves here now
which move he played here very important
move here
yes Bishop d6 absolutely that's a very
good square very powerful square for the
bishop and I I think actually looking at
the game after Bishop d6 I think this
might be lost already so I'm thinking
maybe in this position he should have
actually went back this is what I would
have played 197 here
so if Bishop d6 I can put my knight on
c6 Knight is the best piece to blockade
the past pawn with and here he's
combining the blockade with an attack so
at least now this way I can discourage
this roof from moving I think this is a
much better way to play here he just
probably missed this idea so this would
have been I think tougher tougher to
break through I think this F I was
inaccurate
now we plant the bishop now no more no
more he cannot go there so I played h5
if he would have sit
what's the winning plan here's let's say
he sits on the position like this what
is your winning plan here
f4 with idea f5 break through and open
up the e-file okay h5
and now
Bishop e7 very good Morpheus now again
this is a tough move to play because
you're walking into a fork you know a
lot of times it would be like oh that's
just a fork and we kind of quit you know
we don't look deeper but he had to he
had to understand that that position is
actually very very strong for him very
strong positional exchange sacrifice 9f5
continue take the pawn he takes the rook
and now this is another decision that is
tricky
I mean you actually want to take with
the H pawn because they say I move the
king up i but if you take with the H
pawn you have no advantage actually yeah
yeah okay
f1 yes but it's an endgame and actually
very important to have outside pass pawn
okay this H pass pawn we call that
outside postponed so it's very important
that's why he's doing here because he
wants to have a second pass pawn on h8
now rook g8 he's trying to discourage
you from advancing these pawns what you
can do now
game 3 - excellent he takes don't rush
don't rush now you need to find a way to
push those pawns slowly in the back yes
correct
King g6 now and if you don't play this
move here you have no advantage here
what is the correct move here look f1
excellent protecting that Bishop on a
very powerful square King h7 continue
well you can page you five husband but
you can start with H five attacking that
rook rook h6 don't rush remember you
don't watch just control control g5
h6 see that route so let's say I will
lock this position I just want to see if
you can just win this easily so what's
the plan here can you give me the plan
here there are a few ways to win this so
you also actually can advance your king
and play g6 and make a break there as
well that's another very powerful idea
so let's say you come up he sits on the
position you push takes you take go safe
like a smothering camp now
if he moves away checkmate so and if
it's it's this way right you just push
this one push
you push it goes here and now
how about this and what we call this
position everybody look so on it yeah
we're opponent cannot make any moves
that looks one yeah the German word you
cannot make a move that doesn't damage
your position actually so it's a souk so
on yeah very a very powerful and
impressive play by Kramnik so remember
the ideas yeah fixing the weakness and
not being afraid to even sacrifice the
exchange in the sacrifice the exchange
in the endgame okay and the World
Championship game just to review would
play the Anant was white game number
eight against girl font so it was very
short seventeen move win a very very
tough loss for girl phone that's that's
you really don't when you lose a game
like that you just it's like somebody
else play the game you just you just
can't really find like something to
consult because you know you should see
was all you you just just kind of made a
blonde and lost the game
you